[Música]
a criatividade é fascinante dentro dela
existe vida a vida é minha grande paixão
a vida é feita de experiências de
experiências inesquecíveis
quando eu falo de experiência
eu lembro do meu eu penso no meu leito
de morte
eu quero levar para o meu leito de morte
experiências de vida únicas quando eu
falo sobre a experiência
eu trato de seis dimensões que pra mim
são fundamentais em qualquer experiência
a primeira delas é a dimensão do tempo
a segunda que vem acompanhada
inerentemente ao tempo o espaço
a terceira dimensão é energia que nós
vamos consumir ou nós vamos alocar em
determinada experiência e que dependendo
do nosso propósito que a quarta dimensão
pode ser uma experiência positiva ou
negativa
somada a elas existe a dimensão dos
sentidos como que os nossos cinco
sentidos vão ser capazes de nos
estimular e provocar emoções que daí sim
construam experiências inesquecíveis
essas seis dimensões são fundamentais e
eu acredito que recentemente nós vivemos
uma crise de vida
essa crise de vida é causada por um
esgotamento da nossa era civilizatória
essa crise de vida é acompanhada de
cinco grandes crises que tomaram o
planeta ea civilização nos últimos dez
anos ela começa com uma crise econômica
profunda nos estados unidos e que
provoca a ascensão da china e o
protagonismo do vale do silício
segundo a grande crise está relacionada
diretamente com as mudanças climáticas e
com o impacto nas incertezas que começam
a nos tomar ano a ano em relação à nossa
relação com a natureza
a terceira grande crise está relacionada
diretamente com a revolução urbana que
pela primeira vez na história da
humanidade mais da metade da população
mundial vive em cidades
e nós já somos 7 bilhões de indivíduos a
quarta grande crise está relacionada com
a revolução digital que criou uma
geração inteira de analfabetos digitais
que foram excluídos de uma das maiores
transformações culturais na história da
humanidade ea quinta grande crise que é
resultado disso tudo é a crise
institucional
a sensação de que ninguém nos representa
nós não acreditamos mais na política
nós não confiamos mais nas empresas e
nós nem sabemos se aquilo que os nossos
pais disseram que era certo e errado
como a maneira certa de educar pode ser
transmitida para as futuras gerações e
para os nossos filhos
eu acredito que dessa crise de vida
nós precisamos de uma revolução que nós
chamamos de revolução criativa uma
revolução capaz de criar as novas bases
de uma nova era civilizatória e que
possa construir o futuro da humanidade
no século 21
a revolução criativa precisa antes de
mais nada de um pacto um pacto por duas
coisas fundamentais
o incentivo às idéias ea democratização
do acesso às oportunidades
o incentivo às ideias porque sem
inspiração sem educação para viabilizar
a criação ea viabilização de sonhos
projetos startup de pesquisas
nós não vamos ser capazes
de passar por essa crise que nós vivemos
para isso é fundamental que a gente
democratize o acesso às oportunidades
que tipo de oportunidades oportunidades
de conhecimento que permitam que a gente
saia de um ponto e evolua do ponto de
vista da maturidade de olhar para o
mundo de uma forma crítica a capacidade
de nos conectarmos uns aos outros
seja através de eventos seja através da
tecnologia mas que a gente tem a
oportunidade de nos relacionamos uns com
os outros
uma outra necessidade fundamental e do
reconhecimento ea valorização das idéias
é fundamental que a gente não reprima
aquele que se expressa que a gente tem a
possibilidade de também apresentar um
pouco das nossas loucuras
além disso é fundamental que a gente
tenha acesso a recursos que o
investimento possa fluir seja através de
investimentos públicos e privados ou
através de financiamentos coletivos e
outras estratégias de fomento e de
geração de oportunidade
muitos têm dito que isso está
relacionado com o empreendedorismo
eu sou apaixonado pelo empreendedorismo
eu acho que a atitude de um empreendedor
é fundamental para tirar os sonhos do
papel
mas a equação que a gente tem em relação
ao empreendedorismo não um corpo por um
componente fundamental para a revolução
o empreendedorismo é a soma do
entusiasmo que nós temos com as nossas
ideias
o entusiasmo de enxergar uma
oportunidade na sociedade ou no mercado
e somar a isso a maturidade maturidade
adquirida com o conhecimento
competências e o desenvolvimento de
habilidades mas pra gente poder passar
por essa crise civilizatória e chegar a
um novo estágio aonde a gente consiga
encontrar o equilíbrio entre a
tecnologia
entre a ética entre a economia ea
política
nós precisamos compor o empreendedorismo
com a criatividade o empreendedorismo
criativo o empreendedorismo que respeita
a liberdade de idéias que traz aquilo
que ninguém nunca viu aquilo que fica
dentro de cada um dos indivíduos mas que
dentro de uma de um ecossistema de
incentivo é capaz de transformar a
realidade é que a gente precisa
incentivar para gerar a revolução
a minha mensagem é muito rápida é muito
objetiva
nós precisamos incentivar a criatividade
porque ela é fascinante
a criatividade é capaz de transformar
telhados residenciais em usinas de
energia
ela é capaz de transformar lixo em
riqueza
ela é capaz de transformar células
tronco em cura mas a criatividade ela
precisa vir acompanhada de uma paixão
pela vida a paixão pela vida e por dois
direitos fundamentais a ela a liberdade
para que a gente possa expressar as
nossas ideias para que a gente possa se
conectaram uns com os outros em uma
outra dimensão que não das obrigações e
que a gente tenha acesso à diversidade
que a gente respeite a diversidade entre
os indivíduos entre as culturas e entre
as sociedades sem o respeito à
diversidade nós não vamos adquirir
repertório e nós não teremos a
capacidade de conhecer a fundo todos os
problemas que estão espalhados pelo
planeta pelo planeta e fora dele
então a minha mensagem muito clara que
hoje é que a gente vive um processo de
degradação da civilização como ela foi
construída até agora
pautada na
solução industrial voltada à democracia
representativa e que sem uma grande
revolução criativa que respeite a
liberdade ea diversidade com estratégias
de fomento às idéias e de democratização
de de acesso às oportunidades
a gente não vai ser capaz de mudar a
vida e construir as bases de uma nova
era civilizatória para o século 21
a economia criativa faz parte disso
a inovação faz parte disso a democracia
participativa faz parte disso o
desenvolvimento sustentável e todos os
novos modos de vida economia
compartilhada que são fundamentais e que
precisam ser incorporados no nosso dia a
dia e na nossa defesa como uma causa
para uma nova era a minha fala é muito
rápida mas essa é a mensagem que eu
tenho pra passar
obrigado gente
[Aplausos]